imaginez un soldat de la taille d'un insecte
l'arme secrète ultime que vous donnez
comme des pouvoirs à tout le monde ça va être le
chaos alors comment pouvons-nous arrêter tout je le sais
Écossais
je te regarde depuis un moment
tu es différent et je crois  tout le monde
mérite une chance de rédemption
nous vous
absolument mes jours de cambriolage
et de vol de trucs sont terminés
que voulez-vous que je fasse je veux que vous
pénétriez par effraction dans un endroit et voliez des
trucs logique êtes-vous prêt à devenir le
héros maintenant ce  le costume a du pouvoir
tu dois apprendre à le contrôler
et ce sont tes meilleurs alliés
ils sont plutôt mignons
quand tu es petit tu as une force surhumaine
tu aimes une balle
donc tu dois savoir comment frapper tu
vas me montrer sur un  coup de poing montre-moi
comment frapper c'est comme ça que tu frappes tu as essayé
de me cacher ton costume maintenant ça va t'exploser
au visage et détruire tout le monde se soucie
de
sortir de là
l'avenir
je suis fourmi je sais que ce n'était pas mon idée